Oh, last time we talk about the, uh,
the kind of odd presence of
race in the great Gatsby. Um,
even though there's no African
American character in great Gatsby,
um, there's a kind of undercurrent
of illusions to raise, um,
especially in that seemingly with two
of his scenes when I'm naked and gas via
going into town and Gatsby's car and
they see this other car with three m to
black men and white black woman in
the condo and buy what she'll fill.
So that's a kind of very odd
gratuitous reference. Um,
and I just want to, um, pick up on
that and push that a little further,
uh, because they actually is kind
of a more important, uh, connection,
uh,
of African American music actually
being very important element.
I would say the jazz is,
you know,
started out as an is still very
much, um, African American music.
So I'm Fitzgerald has written than as
they, this is afterward Greg Gas Bay,
but 1931 as a called
echoes of the jazz age. Uh,
and he says it was an age of miracles.
It was an age of odd.
It was an age of access and
it was an age or set higher.
So a lot of those terms,
miracles. Um, there's, um,
you've guys probably know this,
there's a very strong, um,
kind of, um, religious language.
A language of Christianity is son of God,
religious language in the great Gatsby
and miracles would be within that domain
of religious delusions.
Um, but obviously, uh,
with uh, being remapped
onto a secular context, um,
but, um, certainly gas, but you're
someone who would believe in miracles,
the miracle of turning time back and
completely erasing the few years of,
um, bases life. Uh, that's the miracle
that really, um, that he wants to achieve.
Um,
so miracles what Fitzgerald associates
with the jazz age very much as a fairing
in to have the great Gatsby
access. We know about, um,
and age of art as well.
Um,
and there's actually an
illusion in when it goes to, um,
guest ways piloting the music that
was playing. Um, it's actually, uh,
the jazz history of the world.
So lots of cross references
basically kind of a weapon.
Uh,
web of musical web has been a vote and
into the great Gatsby with jazz being
the, the genetic ground of that Web. Um,
so because with the talking and jazz is
really what's important to the 1920s,
not just to Fitzgerald but
to the entire decade. So, um,
just want bring up some of
the employment figures, um,
the piece called,
what did I do to be so black and blue?
That's when specially resonant
peak. Uh, it started out with, um,
fast Waller singing it in, in
this behaving. Um, and then, um,
it was picked up,
both played on the trunk but,
but also sung by Louis Armstrong.
Um,
and Oh, oh, oh,
uh, and um, and then
this is an illusion, uh,
to, uh, Louie Armstrong. Um,
there's this illusion to Louis Armstrong
and Ralph Ellison's invisible man.
And, um, for some reason
that is not showing up here.
So I will, I must, must have raised that
when I was, um, getting ready for this.
So I'll just read this to you.
This is the opening of Ralph
Ellison's invisible man. Um,
then somehow I came out of it sending
hastily from this underground of sound to
hear Louis Armstrong in recently asking,
what did I do to be so black and blue?
So it very much is something that started
out in music and then cross over into
their Azure. Uh, and basically
it was kind of the, um,
under the line,
uh,
concede for Ralph Ellison's invisible man.
I'll put this back on the
PowerPoint when I, uh,
posted to the website. Um,
oh, it's right here. Um,
I can view this way your tricks on
me. Okay. So this is the passage. Um,
and we can um, talk about, um,
music as I'm furnishing a
kind of prometric spectrum to,
uh, to a linguistic medium.
Right? You know, we don't, um,
thing of language necessarily,
um, as having colors. Um,
but language very much has
colors in the way gas page, very,
very striking. Um, Lou
Lou Garden, yellow music,
the blue honey of the Mediterranean,
um,
numerous instances of color have
being used in very abstract ways,
um,
to describe the as as kind of operation
basic operation of the linguistic
medium. So, um, so based on, on this, uh,
the kind of the cross mapping
of music, uh, onto the,
onto the language, um, and, and,
and the generation of color
as well. I mean, you know,
it's kind of very, very odd.
Um, bad. Um,
sight and sound are being combined
in this kind of cross mapping.
So I want to bring those back to the word
that we heard last time from as well.
Perkins.
Um,
his complained really that the
great Gatsby is very vague,
that not enough physical details,
not enough info really
about gas bay. Um, and uh,
last time we talked about it in terms
of what I would call counter realism,
um, and, um, today I'd
like to talk about that,
that sensation of vagueness.
Um,
I let him talk about that in terms of
process mapping of sight and sound,
because this is not something that we
do all the time. It's not common usage.
Uh, it can create impression of pregnancy
even though once we get used to it,
you know, it's just a wonderful, um, um,
strategy that Fitzgerald is using.
Uh,
so the three headings that
I like to, um, use, uh,
for this kind of cross
mapping is first of all, uh,
all Trey feel with colors. We've
already seen a little bit of that, uh,
when Fitzgerald was seemingly
a talking just about sound. Um,
but colors, um, operative,
uh, in those descriptions. Um,
and then the kind of upwards of that
visual feel with Sam or with noise,
lots of noise. There's same exactly
symmetrical to that, but um,
happening on the um, visual. And um,
and then the,
the third really this is the kind of the
central structure that I like to, um,
talk about today,
um,
is this kind of visual auditory
coupling as the medic cubs.
And so first of all, we see, um,
two characters in the same visual or
the same auditory tableau to people
seemingly accidentally being paired
together. We just see them together.
That's the visual impact of that image.
And it turns out that that visual logic,
that visual mode of association
actually has the medic implication.
So the visual,
auditory coupling turning into a
thematic couplings are very complicated
structure.
But I do think that this is something
that a Fisher works very hard to create.
And this is one of the two
just, just miraculous. It was,
I would say, um, um, uh, architecture,
architectural features of the novel.
Um, so, um,
first let's just think about
the auditory field with colors.
Um, and this is, uh,
actually just still had guessed
based party and nick talking about,
um, what he hears there, but
something else as well. Um,
the lice grows brighter as the earth
lodges away from the Sun and now the
orchestra is playing yellow cocktail music
and opera of wizards pitchers are key
hire. Um, so it is
really hearing the music.
This is the occasion when the jazz
history of the world is being clear.
Um,
but it seems that it's impossible
to talk about qualities of sound,
uh,
without thinking of visual images
and not even visual images,
uh, of the people who were there.
Although they are, certainly,
there are plenty of descriptions of those
people, but right now, um, is uh, very,
very, uh, cosmic vision, uh,
after world of Verges,
away from the sun is on
that kind of cosmic scale,
astronomical scale,
um,
that the yellow cocktail
music is pitching into.
Um, so that really the cosmic
reference is coming out of nowhere.
It was very surprising.
Um,
and I'm not sure what to say about it.
And other than that,
it seems very deliberate on, on fish
show up high. So once again, um,
lots and lots of really interesting
details in packed moments,
um,
that invited basically compel
us to give interpretation too.
Um, so this is one end of the
spectrum. All the we feel with colors.
Um, and so let's go to the
other end of the strap spectrum,
the visual optical feel with
noise. Um, and this is once again,
very early,
uh,
when it goes to the big hand in
household for the first time. Um,
and this is, um, he sees these days is
his cousin. He hasn't seen her for awhile.
Um, the first image,
um, that he has of days.
It's actually not a daisy alone,
uh,
but she's on this couch
with another young woman.
The only completely stationary object
in the room was an enormous couch and
wished to young women were Boyd as
though upon an end code barroom balloon,
sorry.
They were both in weight and addresses
with wrestling and fluttering as if they
had just been blown back in after
the short flight around the house.
I must have stood for a few and no one's
listening to the Webinar and snap of
the curtains and the groom
of a picture on the wall.
Then there was a boom.
As Tom,
you can shut the real windows and the
code when died out about the room and the
curtains and the rugs and the two young
women balloon slowly to the floor,
um, is an amazing image. Uh,
and it's that this has a lot
about if you can and household,
it says a lot about things. Uh,
basically is really an, uh, uh,
visual, uh, allegory for
the entire novel. Um,
the entire novel,
the Great Gatsby can be seen as they say,
ballooning, ballooning
up and taking flight. Uh,
going back to that
earlier romance, um, with,
um, with gas may, uh,
but really is just a very racial trail
and she's going to be brought down to
earth by Tom. Um, so it's
a really interesting that,
um, there should be this, uh,
intensification of what my seeing
a very neutral or very casual,
a visual image into something that
carries tremendous. The medic wait, right?
This is basically the whole
story of the great Gatsby.
It's been encapsulated,
encapsulated in this one visual image.
Um,
and what allows this visual image to
have such tremendous thematic way,
it's actually an intrusion
of Sam into that,
into that image. Um, if
they had not been solved,
it would not have been
so pregnant with meaning.
And the sound has to do
with the whip and snap.
We got the curtains.
Um,
it's just remarkable words to use.
Curtains, you know, they don't
make sounds like a web or,
um, they don't make snapping songs. Um,
so clearly this is the super
imposition of something else.
Much more, uh, brutal,
much more violent images being
super imposed on the tree image.
Images being super imposed upon the
otherwise very benign and very harmless
submit by the curtain.
Um,
so or rarely the whip and the snap,
uh,
already behaving to auditory grant for
the appearance from Thailand of Buchanan,
so that when here finally appears towards
the end of the passage is almost not
surprising,
even though he doesn't show up until
the last sentence of the passage.
The snap and whip of the
curtains are ready. Um,
carry a senator. So, you know,
it's really interesting that Tom
Buchanan is a very physical man. He is,
we know him by his physical attributes,
his body filling up every inch of his
clothes, his riding boots and so on,
a very visual figure.
But nonetheless,
fisheries is careful to give an auditory
dimension to Tom. And then the final,
all the trade, but he does is to
bring down shut, do rear window.
This is not the rear door,
but as the rear window,
almost as though somebody is trying to
get into his house by the back door or
the back window.
Um,
and Tommy Canon is shutting that right
then and there before any action is taken
place. So, you know, this is a
forecast. The rest of the novel, um,
is um,
basically it's just a capsule summary
of everything that we need to know about
the great Gatsby. Um, so, um,
just to see how carefully crafted this is.
Um,
because this is already made because
this comes to us readymade um,
we don't notice how, how much, um,
craftsmanship actually
goes into that passage.
So I just wanted to show you a visual
image that is almost similar to theirs up
for by very famous
painter. Um, and they, um,
and this is a picture of car
both where's Mr is reclining. Um,
we also see the curtains in there,
but we just know that those curtains are
not going to make a noise like a web or
they're not going to be making, um,
with whipping or snapping sound.
So this is in contrast to his Gerald.
This is a visual feel without noise
in this completely visual. Um,
it doesn't carry the auditory signature
and auditory manners that as encoded in
Fitzgerald, very careful coupler of
sight and sound in his disruption.
Um, so, um, we also know, uh,
that they see those in the by
herself, right? So it's very,
very important that she and Julien Baker,
the first Glennon's that we have is
after two of them on that enormous couch.
Um,
and both occupants of the visual
field that is carries noise.
So that is the first common thing
between Jordan Baker and they say less.
Go onto see if that visual
auditory counseling, uh,
what does that mean in thematic terms,
how that Stan translate
into futures of the plot.
That may be, we'll also bring
the two of them together. Um,
so I'm telling you what
I'm going to argue with.
It's just the outline of the lecture
and then we'll do the same thing, uh,
with Gatsby and like as well.
But let's just, there's, um,
just move on to Jordan Baker. Um, and um,
last time we talked about the importance
of, uh, the car of as base Rose Rose.
Um,
and the car would really is a key player
and a great Gatsby and all kinds of
contacts. So it turns out
that, um, join Baker, uh,
one very important
aspect of a relation to
Ashley revolves around, um,
the car.
It was that same house party that we had
a curious conversation about driving a
car is started because she passed so
close to some working room than offender
flicks a button on one man's coat.
Will Rogen driver I protested.
Either you are to be more careful
or you on to drive at all.
I am careful. No you're
not. Well other people are,
she said later there was I got to deal
with it. They'll keep out of my way.
She assisted it takes
two to make an accident.
So this says a lot of other motivation
between nick and Jordan Baker and why it
might come to nothing. Um, so, you know,
the Ashley lost of little local
allegories or the entire plot all the way
throughout the great Gatsby and
um, and the fact that she is, um,
a bad driver who's counting on other
people being careful of to prevent
accidents from happening,
that is not a good basis to
get into the marriage with.
And next thing is to know that.
So I mean this is really one of the many
signs that this is not going to come to
anything. Um, but well,
it's also interesting I think
about this particular um,
image of Julien Baker coming by way
of her relation to the automobile is a
notion of accountability that is
perhaps not just limited to Jordan.
Baker herself is really an account,
uh,
an explanation of why things go wrong
and one's responsibility once input,
once contribution to the fact
that something is going on wrong.
And for Jordan Baker Accountability is
almost always written over to the other
side.
If there's an accident is because
the other person isn't a good driver.
That's why there's an accident taking,
not taking into account at all.
The fact that she's also a bad driver.
I'm just right that it takes two
to make an accident. Um, but the,
the explanation there's she's looking
for is that in the other person's fault.
Um,
and we'll see that there are other
characters in the novel who share that
understanding of accountability.
Um,
kind of a straight attribution
of thought to the other side.
Um, so let's see, um, what they say,
how they say relates to the car and
it turns out this year also as a very
extremely non trivial relation
to the car. Um, this is,
well they are leaving that um,
terrible scene in New York when
basically Gaspe is just falling apart.
Um, but he's, Tom, um, allows
him to drive these back.
So nick that Gatsby and daisy in the car,
this is gas. Me telling me what
happened when we left New York.
She was very nervous and she thought
it was there either to drive.
And this woman rushed out of,
just as we were passing a
car coming the other way.
It all happened in a minute,
but they seem to me that
she wanted to speak to us,
thought we were somebody she knew.
Well,
first Nazy turned away from the
woman toward the other than car,
and then she lost her nose and told back.
So as the death of motto
at the hand of Daisy,
and,
um,
it is not intentional and I think
that this says a lot about these Z.
Um,
Fitzgerald is not portraying
I'm a bad person really.
Um, she is a bad driver because
she's lost her nerve. Um,
and we really have to be pretty
careful, um, in our assignment of blame.
Um,
I think that Jordan Baker is a very,
almost too clear assignment of
blame in putting it squarely, um,
or the other person's site.
Um,
and the first Arrow is actually
quite now for, um, about, um,
seeing what kind of woman Bec
is another very brief person.
Um,
and she's not a very feisty person.
She doesn't have steadily is the,
that stood in as of nerve.
Um, and she'll do Susan the nerve at a
critical moment and both at this very
critical moment. But also, uh,
in the kind of abstract way, uh,
when gas being needed her to stand by him,
which is really not there for him.
Um,
so this is the kind of person she is
and it comes out most dramatically,
um, in her handling of the car. Um,
but it also comes out in a way that she
handles other affairs of life as well.
Um,
so in all those ways we see the same
kind of logic that we saw last time that
it's very important.
Human attributes are rooted,
are channeled through, um,
our relation to objects,
bases,
relation to the car says a lot.
How about how she would behave you
another go strictly human contacts of
interaction.
Um,
so John Baker and they say we're
joined together at the very beginning,
uh,
by virtue of that visual tableau.
And it turns out that it actually
is a very deep connection. They,
they're both bad drivers, uh, although
for bad reasons. So, you know,
we have to be careful as well.
They're both bad drivers.
But in the case of Jordan Baker,
she's just much more cavalier about the
whole thing. Whereas Stacy is just not,
it's just incompetent and not
very skilled and lacking earth.
Um,
so let's turn on turn back
now to another coupling.
Um, and you guys will notice
that I'm not talking about, um,
Gatsby and daisy, the most obvious
couple and the great gas where, uh,
but I want to talk about that a couple of,
uh,
in a roundabout fashion actually
by way of Nick and Gasper.
And I just want to go back to one various
more point that we talked about much
earlier. Um, and which is
about the legacy of Whoa, Whoa,
one,
right.
So we know that nick and
Gas Bay have this in common.
They both fought in world war one,
and, um, they both name the, the, the,
the, the unit that they were in. Um,
so nick was in the nine machine
gun battalion and gets me,
was in the seventh infantry,
um,
very precised in naming
the number of that unit.
So erratic. We know that
there's a prior connection, uh,
between the two of them.
And I would argue that they also have an
ongoing connection as well because they
are both very, very, uh,
sensitive to responsive to and captivated
by a certain quality of sound that
resize and daisies
boys. So, um, it's very,
very hard that Neko is,
has no romantic attachment.
Two days there should be captivated and
almost exactly the same way that Gatsby
is captivated.
It doesn't actually take a romantic
attachment for it to be completely within
the powers of a certain quality of voice.
So like talking about these boys,
it was the kind of voice that ear follows
up and down as if each speech isn't an
arrangement of nurse that will never
be the way the Gan her face was sad and
lovely with Bray things and the right
eyes and the brain passionate mouth.
But there was an excitement in their
voice that men who had care for her found
difficult to forget this thing.
Compulsion of wisdoms less than.
Um,
when we look at the visual
description of daisy,
um,
it's not very striking.
Fitzgerald using very frigid
and narrative was to talk about,
they say the face is sad and lovely.
Would break things and almost no actual
description of the fear of the physical
features on Daisy's phase. So it
actually is a kind of variable, very,
um, image of days as we know
that supposedly she's beautiful,
but we don't actually know in what way
she is the exact features that renderer
beautiful.
Um,
it is a voice that gives a
very accent rendition of,
they say it is voice
to know the can forget.
Nobody who cares about her can forget.
Um,
and in this case it is really
the intonation of mortality
rate and I think that
for us, um, well I mean now
we can capture as bubbles,
legion sound calling
mixed that less, uh, of a,
a kind of internationally on
mortality. But, um, it's just,
just avoids the, you're here for that one
law and, and you'll never hear it again.
You do have the sense that it's
just that one time and uh, it will,
uh,
never again be heard again.
You go to a concert
that's not being recorded,
then you just know that this is it. Um,
you know, once it's gone, it's gone. Um,
and so that partly accounts for the
compulsion that comes from Daisy's voice,
um, that, um,
it both is integration of all the hurt
and mortality and this an intonation and
mortality on the part of the
person who is listening to her. Um,
let's look at one other description
of this voice coming from neck.
Uh, this is something that we
actually read the, but I just started,
would read it again for a moment.
The last sunshine fell out of romantic
affection of Ohio glowing phase before
has compelled me forward.
Breathlessly as I listen,
that glow faded each light discerning,
more lingering regret,
pleasure than meaning of the
lesson street at dusk. Um,
and this was actually in
the context of, um, nick,
this is the visit to be Canon Household,
um,
and make us just about to found out
about toms affair with myrtle. Um,
so in some sense to count the
fading light is also, um, uh,
kind of, uh, created, uh, or
perhaps even an rate of, uh,
the randomly feeling light.
Even in the course of that evening.
As the phone rings, all the light
goes out, uh, of everyone's face.
Uh, and so, uh, it's, it's,
it's, um, it's, it's the,
it's the quality of sound that registry
that registers with dramatic development
in that, in that episode. Um, so
let's look up. So you know, as I said,
really, you know, doesn't have a
deep relation to today's eight, uh,
but he has a very deep
relation to Daisy's voice. Um,
and gas me who was a very deep relation
today say also has very deep information
to please. It's for us as well.
Um, and this is the moment, uh,
when he's meeting daisy after all
these years and next house. Um,
and uh, we'll read that
passage a little later. Um,
but they conjectures that has been
killing her in his heart for so long that
this is actually not
the big moment for him.
This is actually the moment of the led
down that here is this woman who's been
waiting for that you guys doing everything
building up his whole life towards
this moment. Um, and it's
a kind of a let down. Um,
and so he niggas notice and in Gaspe and
then something else happens as I watch
him,
he adjusted himself visible way.
His hand took hold of
hers and as she says,
something low in his ear,
he turned toward her
with a rush of emotion.
I think that voice held him most with
is fluctuating feverish one because it
couldn't be over dreamed
that voice was Adele,
this song.
So everything else about days,
they actually could be an is overtrained
and Gaspe almost no staff that he's
project that much,
too much on two days.
There was no way she can live up to all
the projections about those years that
he's been involving her. And um, so she,
no one,
no human being is not just the days that
you can live up to that kind of massive
projection and the politics of gasping.
No European can.
But one thing about daisy can
stand up to that magnification.
Emotional annification application on
a part of daisy of gas made and that is
the voice. Um, every time,
anytime he hears his voice,
he's captivated, captivated by
her, over the law. Again, as a,
everything has really starting right at
that moment. So the voice for the Esa,
um, captures the possibility
of fresh beginning. Um,
it seems to have content and is themes
to have arrived in the moment and where,
uh,
gets bits,
find the solution with asa and then
that he hears that voice again.
And it's almost as if
there's a fresh start.
And this is really what
Fitzgerald talks about,
about the new world and the fresh
green grass of the new world.
The very end of the great Gatsby is
that some people actually have the
capability for endless new beginnings.
You know,
your thing that they've come to
the anode Europe, uh, and all that,
the come to the end of the dream and all
of a sudden they're selling up all over
again. Um, and that's really
was impressive about gas bay.
Sad and pathetic about Gatsby as well,
but also impressive is that
he can always start again,
that passion for gas. You
can always start afresh, um,
because of the quality of these staff.
But guess what,
it's not so captivated.
Also blindly in love that he
doesn't know what is in that voice.
What constitutes that for us or what
gives the voice is magical power.
So this is actually a surprisingly,
uh,
cleared I evaluation of basis,
voice from gas vapor.
The voice is for money.
He said like,
that was it. I never understood
before. It was full of money.
That was the inexhaustible
charm that rose and fell.
And then the jingle of it,
the symbol song of it,
hi in a white powers,
the king's daughter,
the so usually people who are madly in
love and not so great and analyzing the
nature of the object that they
have in a kind of surprising move,
gasping actually is very analytical
here and completely right. Um, that,
that really is the power of the easy.
That in some sense she used to go and
go in a very literal sense that it is to
go, that makes for that Goldman's
of the say, um, that, uh,
that's really what creates her,
that gives her initial, uh,
magic over a gas bay when he
was just a poor young boy. Um,
and that's what makes of continue
magic of they say that yes,
this is an Asian miracle, um, as, um,
as as Fitzgerald assess
and, um, about jazz. Um,
but it is an Asian miracle,
um,
underwritten by two miracle
creating power of gold.
Um, this is really what the
novel is about is um, this,
this magic in as well.
Um,
but it's coming from a basically
an inanimate nonhuman source.
Um,
and I'm a human being can quite often
be the creation of that miracle working
substance goal. Um, so, um,
so far we've seen the two of them,
uh,
being completely catch captivated
by, by this, his voice. Um,
but nick and gas may also have
something else in common as well.
Um,
and in that,
even though sung is what keeps them
going for a good part of the novel, um,
Ashley at some point,
Sam is also extinguish for them.
So let's look at the mode by which song
is being extinguished for each of them.
Um,
and not surprisingly,
those come at the end of the novel
because when sound and sustain,
which that's also a signal that
novel was coming to an end.
So here is um,
nick actually watching Tom and daisy
after the accident when Tom Daisy back in
the house,
um,
and nick is outside and so he's watching
the two of them and all I can see is
this visual tableau of Tom and they see
it but he can hear what they're saying.
Um, and I think we can really actually
get them more dramatic moment when you can
only see but not here they say.
And Tom was sitting opposite each other
at the kitchen table with a plate of
coal fried chicken between
them and two bottles of our,
he was talking intently across the
table at her and his earnestness,
his hand had fallen upon and
covered her own once in awhile.
She looked up at him and
nodded in agreement there
weren't happy and neither of
them had touched the chicken,
all the gale.
And yet they weren't unhappy either.
There was an unmistakable heir of
national intimacy about the picture and
anybody with us then that
they were conspiring together.
So this absolutely is the happy
ending and heavy quotation marks,
uh,
for daisy and Tom,
the reconstitution of that marriage,
um,
that had come under so much
threat from both sides,
modal and Gatsby. And this is another
way in which mother and Gatsby,
um, uh, linked together. They're both
people are coming from a
different social circle, um,
trying to destroy that marriage.
Um, they are not successful.
The marriage survives. Um,
and this is the comedy.
This is the happy ending for Tom and
daisy and the nature of that comedy.
And obviously I'll be, and ironic
here, the nature of the comedy, um,
is that, uh, it's just the
two of them. So, you know,
really the marriages between the two of
them are even her cousin can only watch,
uh, but cannot actually here what has
been said between the two of them. Um,
so this is,
um,
a happy moment for Tom and daisy that
for NEC has to the experience as silence,
uh,
from the part of Basie and from Tom.
He so used to hearing her
voice in this one, um,
instant.
He is not hearing those always alarmed.
That's because she's talking to Thomas
was not talking to nick. So, um,
let's look at a comparable,
a symmetrical moment of
sound being extinguished, uh,
by gas. This is a truly unforgettable
moment. And uh, once again, the,
the other objects that uh, within, um,
all the artists that are important
in the first part of the great Gatsby
actually come back and play a
very important one. So the snow,
the establishing of staff for gas and
towards the end of the great Gatsby
actually comes by way of telephone.
Um,
nothing coming through to
him from the telephone.
He was waiting for obviously
for the coffin. Daisy,
no telephone message arrived,
but the Butler when without sleep
and waited for it until four o'clock,
until long after there was
anyone to give it to. Evan came,
I have an idea.
The gas himself didn't believe it would
come and perhaps that you no longer care
if that was true. He must have
felt that he had lost all warm,
well paid,
a high price for living too
long with a single dream.
He must've looked up at an unfamiliar
sky through frightening leaves.
And should I say a little
road to has claim arose is,
and how raw the soundbite was upon us.
The ghastly created grass.
Um,
we see the fairy carefully plan transition
from the silence of the telephone
once again to us frequently
visional tableau. Um,
so this is exactly
symmetrical to the seen,
witnessed by nature,
um, the suspension, uh,
non appearance of sad,
um,
and then the domination
of the visual field.
And now finally,
business or visual feel without some,
it hasn't been the case before.
It's been a visual field
with Sam here is low.
And when we get the visual feel without
sa and all of a sudden it's a protest
field, we don't tend to think of the
rose cause a very core task thing.
But when you're bad up close to the rose,
when you're saying it and such,
my new futures, the rose becomes a very
grotesque, unbearable to look at really.
Um, and that's really what the world
is for, for, for gasping at that point.
So, um, right now we've, um,
talk about the two of them.
Um, Nate and gasp as if they were
almost exactly of like, right. You know,
they just seem, this is very strong
symmetry between the two of them,
but honestly this is really non exactly.
I experienced those two characters
either as we read the Great Gatsby,
the two of them,
and also exactly like that they are
so that they are interchangeable.
Um, so, um, I want now to start another,
uh, train of thought that
actually points to a difference.
The train neck and gas
bear, um, nick against bit,
um, have, uh,
very important common grog up to a certain
point and then they dive for church
after that, after the point. So as
Trey's, the divergence between the,
it turns out that Sung is extinguish,
uh,
for nec in Jude Romantic scenes,
not hearing daisy talking to Tom.
That's one moment, but there's
another one, not as dramatic,
but equally consequential for him.
Um,
and actually it also comes by
way of a phone conversation.
So at least there's that cemetery
between [inaudible] and gas. Me as well.
Um, but here's a, they
talking to John Baker.
Suppose I don't go to Southampton and
this is after they accident. Uh, so those,
I don't go to Southampton and
come into towns after afternoon.
No I don't think this afternoon very
well is impossible this afternoon.
Various,
we talk like that for awhile
and then abruptly we weren't,
sorry we weren't talking any longer.
I didn't know of us hung
up with the shop clip,
but I know I didn't care.
So here too is a phone conversation
that simply turns into the kind of non
conversation and then silence
descending on the two of them.
So it seems this thing
obviously is very free,
close to the silence or
telephone for guests with,
but there is a crucial difference.
Nick had conjecture earlier that gas
began care if the phone call came or not.
But that's obviously not true. How
will he not care? It was devastating.
It was devastating. But there was no
phone call from, from, from, from,
from daisy.
But this is the moment when
nick truly doesn't really care.
And he doesn't care because of who he is.
So now we've come to a very important
providing of the ways between nick and
Gatsby. Gatsby is someone
who actually cares so much.
There's almost as if there's no reason
for them to live after that moment. Um,
and so, you know, it's fitting that he
should die right then and there. Um,
the pilot was kind of
reflecting his psychology, um,
but make to someone who doesn't care and
who survives in some sense because he
doesn't care. So here's a
moment to go back to, um,
Sunday that Fitzgerald and
Hemingway actually have in common.
We talked a lot about the
logic of substitution and
having weight and especially
the [inaudible] horse being the
substitute for the picador, uh,
when a ball is charting. Um,
so there's a very important,
largely goes up to tuition in Hemingway.
And it turns out that there's also a
logic of substitution in the great Gatsby
as well,
is if only because the worst substitute
is actually use by Fitzgerald,
um, once again in seemingly
with two of those contacts.
So this is the family
history of neck caraway.
The actual founder of my life was my
grandfather's brother who came here in 51
send a substitute to the civil war,
has started the wholesale hardware
business that my father carries on today.
Okay.
This entire passage,
when we first read it seems to nothing
to do with the rest of the novel.
You know,
why would we care whether or not
back one generation and now even his
grandfather. But it's when
his uncle great uncle, um, uh,
send a substitute,
didn't fight.
So this actually has a lot in
common with the Hemingway story.
This is some one who doesn't fight his
own battles and as a substitute to fight
for him and to suffer with him
in the civil war. Um, and um,
and then as a consequence of surviving
because of not having died in,
so while being able to found a
very successful hardware business.
So all these details about Nick's family
history at the moment when it appears
very early com, first opening
pages of the Great Gatsby, um,
seems simply just to stand
there and to be doing nothing.
And it's only in hindsight that,
um,
we can imbue meaning.
We can retrospectively impute and meaning
to our original seemingly gratuitous
detail.
Um,
and it really has to do with the vital
difference between Gas Bay and Nick.
And here is this moment when just before,
uh,
gas phase captivated by
and pieces was again,
this is the moment of this
illusion but also we illusion,
um, than, than it gives no
listening and gasping. Uh,
there must have been [inaudible]
even that afternoon when there is a,
is a Moo Shu sure of his dreams,
not through home,
fall through because of the colossal
vitality, obviously illusion.
It had gone beyond the,
beyond.
Everything hits from ind himself
into it with a creative passion,
adding to it all the time,
decking it out with every bright
feather that drifted his way.
No amount of fire or freshness can
challenge with American store up in this
ghostly hot.
So this is really why
gas bay is what he is,
is that he has this enormous
storage capacity in his goes late,
hard and it was store on daisy
will be stored there forever.
It almost doesn't matter who, who she
is, what she really turns out to be.
And what he finds,
what he realized,
we finally realized is what she is.
It almost doesn't matter.
It has no relation to reality at all
off because it is strictly a dream about
days, a bad gas, the histo
in his own heart and mind.
So the colossal vitality
of illusion in Dallas.
What death is about daisy and gas base.
Oh mine.
And what enables gas bay today deathless
to some extent as well in spite of his
physical biological that um,
with nick is the other way around.
So just want to read you,
um, why he doesn't care. Um,
and why it turns out that
his family business is the,
is the hardware business.
Um,
it is someone who can never be
hurt by anything that happens. Uh,
10 [inaudible] was [inaudible] is honors.
She wasn't able to enjoy
being at a disadvantage and
given this on willingness,
I suppose she had begun
dealing and subterfuges when
she was very young and all
that to keep that cool insulin smile,
turn to the world and yet satisfy the
demands of her heart Shaunti body.
We have seen gas may and
very analytical about these,
right that she is,
the voice is full of money and here
is performing a comparable analytic
operation on children Baker that
she's just encapsulate as honest.
You can bear to lose.
She would do anything she can to and
he is rape that rate about joining.
And that's why, you know, the
marriage is not going to take place.
But one of that is not even that she's
nice, such a great marriage companion. Um,
it is that they really doesn't even care
enough to be hurt by that realization.
Um,
he is insulated by the emotional hardware
that has been his family's business
for these two generations.
Um,
and so that's why the family history is
so important to nick and why he really
needs a substitute,
uh,
because he is simply incapable of feeling
the kind of apps to see that gaspy is
capable of feeling,
nor is he capable of feeling
the devastation that as
beer is capable of feeling.
Those two go ahead and hand. You get
ecstasy, you get those Asian, um,
and nick is not capable of either.
Um, and that's why he's such a good,
such good friends with,
with Guzman was always standing by
gasping because he really needs that in
direct experience of what it feels to be
in the gas space mind.
And to have that ghostly hard with
his mere was storage capacity.
Um, so anyway, um, this is, um, um,
of kind of Fitzgerald's way of
encouraging us to think about different
constellations, right?
Different configuration,
different constellations of characters,
um,
and nick and Gatsby and not
the most obvious couple. Uh,
but it turns out that actually the whole
story of the great Gatsby can be taught
by looking at this nontraditional couple.
Uh,
and I'll encourage you in session two.
Think of other nontraditional
couples as well,
and we'll turn to a fist to Faulkner.
That's weak.